and you're more nervous than i am oh
yeah no i get very nervous but
i'm i'm hoping to i like it yeah fail
better each time and and not just aim
for good
well see that's another thing my acting
teacher used to always say
uh when you're nervous before
performance don't try to get rid of
nervousness
bring it with you into the scene because
it's a it's an authentic emotion and as
he put it
never deny an authentic emotion
on stage or in front of a camera never
deny it
never try to cover it up so if in the
middle of a scene you start laughing
laugh if in the middle of the scene
you're nervous let that nervousness be
there
when i do a poetry reading i am always
ask my wife she'll tell you my palms get
sweaty and i'm a wreck
and and i want to be i know that's good
i go okay good
it means i'm alive because if i was dead
i wouldn't be nervous
but if you're alive you're afraid of
failure and if when you're afraid of
making a fool of yourself
in front of 20 or 100 people you get
nervous well that's good
i should be nervous and what i try to do
is not to dissipate it the nervousness
is really my friend because it means i
am connected to this
moment when i get up and i open you know
my book of poetry and i go
okay my first poem is going to be you
know blah blah blah
if if i'm confident i i i'm going to be
boring
you know confidence is really pretty
you know there's nothing worse than
seeing somebody
think they know everything it's it's
boring when you're performing when
you're acting when you're reading
um so if you are nervous
hold on to it it's your friend
let it be and when you start to read
whatever that poem is a story
if the poem makes you you're nervous
it's because there's something at stake
you might be writing about
the time your father came home drunk and
you
you've tried to stop him from leaving
and you pushed him down and he fell and
here you are 12 years old and you feel
like you just
knocked your dad out or
maybe you're writing a poem about when
you were in
in italy and you were 19 and you got a
phone call
from the father of the boy you were
traveling with
and he tells your son you have to come
home you're the man in the family now
and you don't even want to admit that
you know what that means
so you say what i i don't understand
of course you understand he's telling
your father died
but you know what i don't understand he
said son
you're the man in the family now
well you know that's that's a moment
that i really
relive and remember it was like my whole
world caved in
i was in lake como in italy and
uh it just changed my life it just i
i never thought that would happen i my
father was like the most important man
in my life
and if you're writing something about
that
then you should be nervous it should
bring you into the heart of your
feelings whatever there might be for me
it was
absolute terror just terror that
i would not know what to do i felt my
father
was the wisest man i ever knew
and that even though i was 19 i felt
that
he would tell me the secret of life
and he hadn't told it to me yet but he
was going to
and when he died i thought
i'll never know what the secret of life
is i'll never know
how to survive because i want to be an
artist
and i don't know how you make a living
as an artist so maybe he would tell me
but he wasn't there anymore and i was
like lost for years
because of that and even now when i'm
talking about it i'm
i'm getting all um i'm feeling that
feeling i had when i was
just scared shitless
about life that i wouldn't know what to
do
and you know the funny thing about it is
it's been
i don't know 60 years since my dad died
and
i'm still not sure i know what the
secret of life is and i'm still not sure
i know
how to survive i can't believe i've
survived this long but i have but i
don't believe it i don't
i don't get it i don't understand it i
don't know how people survive
you know i always think they know
something i don't know
so nervousness is good
how are how are fathers days for you
how what father's day june 20th how was
that
father's day you mean when when i'm
the father of my son and any any time
father's day comes up
i i you know once my son was born it was
more a question of me being
the father to him
and so that's what father's day was for
me that you know he would
uh get me something or write me a card
and every card he wrote i've saved them
i've got him
on the on my bookshelves you know so i
can see him and
you know he always would make me a
father's day card um
you know i never thought about that um
i i think about my father so much or did
think about him so much
that i don't think i reserved one day
that today is going to be the day i
think about them
i thought about my father so much
especially when i was
unsure or in trouble or
worried or whatever i would think what
would my father do what would he
say what would wha you know what would
he tell me
so i i don't need father's day you know
i i
but he died when he was 50
i think so when i made 54
i remember thinking okay
because i always thought will you live
to be as old as he was
at the time 54 seemed like uh
a very old but when i was 54 i
i felt like i just got started my son
was about five years old so i became a
father when i was 49.
so um you know i uh
at 54 i thought okay all the
okay now it's it's it's me
you know it's not him now it's now you
know it's my turn
i've got to do it so that was a big
year for me when when i had turned 54.
was it easy for you to write about this
i've written about
my relationship with my father many
times
in different ways um
and my mother too who was a kind of a
crazy according to my therapist a
paranoid schizophrenic
so i wrote about my mother too but i've
written about my father i've written
about
being a father when josh was born and i
would have to go to safeway and get
diapers and enfamil
the the milk you know that you drink so
i've written about father issues
quite a bit um you know buckowski has
that great poem about his own father
when he goes to his house after his
father dies and
he puts on uh his father's suit
which hangs on him a little
loose um the poem is called the twins
because he looks at himself in the
mirror and he thinks okay
now i'm my father so we could be twins
so um
i guess you wrestle with your father one
way or the other
those who've had good fathers those who
had bad fathers
my dad was a wise man a great man
loved by everyone he also had a problem
uh he was an alcoholic and a lot of
anxiety in my family growing up
i'm a quote adult child of alcoholics
you know that that was the thing
um but i didn't i don't know if i wrote
about him a lot
after i got to be 54. i think at that
point i kind of
thought well okay i got this far without
knowing
anything maybe i can i can go the rest
of the way without knowing anything
and i still don't know anything you know
every day when i wake up in the morning
i said
you know i i try to guess what time it
is by the light
you know the light outside that
beginning of dawn
and i try to guess what time it is and
i'll i'll look over and i'll see what
time it is and i'll think to myself
okay another day another day to
write your poems and teach and
be you know love your friends and love
the world
so that's a long answer to
to a very simple question you asked
where's the green tape
no i don't want you to talk it's great i
like it
i know there's a lot of emotion i
remember there was a clerk
at a grocery store and i'd seen the
person many times and i was
sort of friendly with them and and i'm
not it was father's day
and the clerk so i forgot
what happened and he said you're not
wishing me a happy father's day and i
could see
how hurt he was and he goes you think
that just because i'm older i don't you
know and i could just see it was like a
real wound to this person
yeah and i i said to him you know the
reason i didn't wish you that is because
father's day wasn't a thing for me i
never knew mine so
that was why so we were both coming to
it with these two different things but
yeah i could see
even he was he was still you know this
was very hard for him and here he was
behind this cashier trying to
save face and you know i just remember
that being a very um interesting moment
i never forgot it
yeah we don't have a lot of moments like
that with people we don't know
i kind of knew him just just i would
joke with him and
and i actually never saw him after that
i don't know what happened to him but
hopefully he's okay but um anyway i'm
going off on a tangent but i guess what
i'm trying to say is that
we don't know some you know fatherhood
motherhood all those things are very
these are very sort of deep you talk
about the deep voice
yeah these are things that we all carry
our own
wound or whatever with us you know yeah
and
um you don't know whether you're
supposed to play a role or
what is it to be a father
you know i i remember when my wife was
pregnant
i when she called me on the phone to
tell me she was pregnant
the first thought i thought was okay now
now it begins
meaning i have to take life seriously
and then
the night her water broke we were
watching
um sleeping with the enemy a movie on tv
and it was about 11 o'clock at night you
know
you you always want your water to break
in the morning
so you can go to the hospital and you've
had a good night's sleep but no it was
11 o'clock at night we were exhausted
and our water breaks and we're driving
to the to kaiser and i i stop at a
ralph's or something and i get ice
because they said something about
you know she can have eyes or something
like that i don't know what it was
but i went into the ralphs with the neon
lights and everything was real
bright and it was 11 11 30 at night
and again i just had that got a little
ice chest put the ice in
i remember thinking okay this is it
you know we knew it was a boy your son's
going to be born
very soon and your life is going to
totally change
so there was that feeling that
everything was going to be different
well nothing really changes you just go
on day by day
being and dealing with what you have to
deal with
but in my imagination i thought you know
it was like
okay show time you know it's like you're
doing a play
and they go you're on and then you have
to walk out there and
i'm the father where's my lines
and they go um uh there are no lines
i go what do you mean i go well we don't
have any lines well there's got to be
lines i mean i'm a father
what's what's the what's the you know
what's the role what do i got to do
and they go oh i don't know and they go
are you a father yeah but i don't know
what the hell to do
well anybody here know what to do no i'm
in front of 500 people here what am i
going to do
well you got to be a father yeah but
what is that about
i don't know so you just go and do it
you know that whatever role you think it
is it's not what you think it's going to
be
i remember when josh was
in third grade
i was driving him to school and my son
is
very stubborn i don't know where he gets
it
i think he gets it for me of course uh
he's really stubborn i mean
you know you don't tell josh what to do
and we're in the car and i don't know we
got into something he and i
and my wife would always say don't make
it a
fight you know i couldn't help it you
know i'm going to hold my position he's
going to hold his
and before you know it i'm kind of
yelling and screaming and
we're just driving it's a mess we get to
school
and it was my day to go to the kids
and teach them how to write poetry so
i tell them you know write about
something true and
anyway i walk around the room and watch
what the kids are writing just to see if
they're doing okay
sometimes a kid maybe doesn't quite know
how to get started and i
help him and there's my son writing
about me yelling and screaming in the
car
now i usually have the kids get up and
read
and there was no way i could not have
him
do it if he wanted to because i that
would be a bad lesson
to teach him so when it was time to read
i said okay who wants to read first
josh raises his hand i go oh
so he walks up opens it up and he's
writing about being in the car with his
dad who's yelling and screaming
and the kids are like i mean they're
they're loving it and at the same time
they're a little shocked
and i know they're all looking at me
they want to see how am i going to react
to it
and i just listened to it like i was
listening to a piece of writing and then
when he was finished i went
good good i said you know the part there
where you
mentioned that you could write a little
more about that you know make it
now as i responded to it like it was a
piece of writing
worthy of being commented on uh
but you know how do you plan for
something like that
you know they're the kids i'm the
teacher and he's
writing about me you know being a kind
of
uh not very empathetic father
so you know i don't know whatever's in
the handbook
it wasn't in the handbook i got you just
sort of stumble your way through and
hope you do your best
i think that's why in saving private
ryan
um at the very end of the movie
when he he goes to the grave
of the major who saved his life
and you know he's an old man now and and
he
hopes that that his life was
worthy of being saved
i broke down in the movie theater
because
the way i related to it was
at that point when i saw the movie i
hope my life will be worthy
as a father as a husband as a friend
and i mean i was just it's probably the
most i've cried in a movie ever in my
life
when he said i hope my life will be
worthy
so you make a lot of mistakes you fail
right you fail and when you fail you you
got to go
well this is what's supposed to happen
and that day that josh wrote this
piece about the car ride over that was
the deeper voice
yeah it was a deep voice and he was
writing about something that was
like pretty brave gutsy of him to write
about that
you know i mean i'm his father i'm the
teacher
i'm coming into the classroom as the
teaching everyone how to write and i'm
telling them
a matter of fact i read a poem by my own
father come to think of it that's
part of the lesson so he went and did it
you know
bravo for him so
like i said you i i had to validate that
i
i couldn't uh one tell him no no don't
read that josh
it'll make me look bad well if it made
me look bad
too bad because what he wrote was good
and as a teacher and as a father i have
to reinforce
for him that this is how you make art
you tell the truth you
you take risks you write about
what's hard to write about
you